riposte contre un symbole en france
aussi un restaurant mcdonald's a été
pris pour cible c'était aujourd'hui à
millau dans l'aveyron les agriculteurs
français voulaient ainsi dénoncer des
sanctions commerciales américaines
contre plusieurs de nos produits dont le
roquefort originaire précisément de
cette région car didier la cible un
restaurant en construction de la chaîne
mcdonald's plusieurs dizaines de
personnes essentiellement des
producteurs de lait de brebis ont
saccagé le chantier les manifestants
proches de la confédération paysanne
entendait ainsi répondre à la décision
américaine qui impose 100 % de droits de
douane sur le fromage de roquefort en
rétorsion douanières qui ont fait suite
à l'interdiction européenne
d'importation de boeuf aux hormones
américain
les manifestants auraient détruit 50 %
du chantier sans que les forces de
l'ordre interviennent ils ont emporté
symboliquement des matériaux de
construction dans l'attende une levée
des sanctions américaines
aujourd'hui moi les problèmes
communautaires et internationaux
nouveaux commerces à ne dépasse
complètement
moi je suis un chef d'entreprise local
ici qui vont recruter 35 personnes oui
car le territoire et en bas et qui était
un travail et aucune autre prise locales
pour qu'on soit 100 mag d'or les paysans
ne sont pas les seuls dans le
département de l'aveyron à s'en prendre
aux symboles de l'industrie
agroalimentaire d'outre-atlantique
également signe de protestation contre
les sanctions douanières américaines
trois cafetiers de rodez refus désormais
de servir du coca cola